mx one of these walls has ten thousand
dollars behind it one has nothing and
one has a thousand dollars pick a wall
oh man oh i like blue let's go with blue
let's see what's behind the yellow wall
this is what you said no to oh
jeez hey
good choice yellow sucks now let's see
what's behind the red wall you said no
to these
oh
that hurts that means you just won a
thousand dollars
awesome more than i started with reflux
you are in an abandoned island in the
middle of the ocean and i buried
treasure below this island if you can
find it before the end of this video you
win 10 000
what now
start go go go dude hurry up
okay we have to find this what were you
gonna do today so i was gonna go on a
date but i kind of canceled let's go
if you're watching this sorry for making
them late to your date i have them
digging for a random chest for 10 grand
i hope you don't mind i'm sorry cub do
you see that 500 over there if you push
this button you could double the money
or lose it all
wow
oh push it again
2 thousand dollars
one of these pushes is gonna light that
tnt blow it up and you'll lose it all oh
that's unfortunate
if you stop right now i'll give you
eight thousand dollars but if you press
it again you can lose it
yeah
i'll send you a thousand dollars just
because i feel bad and next contestant
border if you turn around you'll see a
house is currently on fire every time a
block is burned you lose a dollar go put
out the fire oh oh my god you're losing
money quick oh dear god i need to see
the house this is not good 3 800 already
all the blocks are going fast jimmy
you're down to 3 500 you've always lost
their grand here i'm gonna help you look
i'm helping
just a little bit
border just put out the fire i'm trying
how did this fire get down here carl i
don't know it's kind of bad though huh
carl's just a meanie oh not the library
i gotta save the library border your
logs on fire porter oh i wonder what
happened to the lawn all right
congratulations porter you have
successfully put out the fire and won
three thousand forty six dollars this is
a parkour map and gentlemen can you look
up at that timer up there if you
complete this course before it hits zero
you get five grand if not it blows up go
go go go go
stay on the green oh you failed kill
switch is leaving him in the dust
oh no kill switch has to restart oh by
the way only one of you is winning five
grand what do you have to say to your
competitor please fall right down to the
bottom that'd be very helpful
like that oh i've got such a big lead as
well i gotta get up
oh he got past the ladders what are you
doing speed it up
oh
hey hey wait i ate it ate it one minute
remaining okay i got it i got it i got
it oh you have to
clean
what are you doing hey just to show this
really isn't that hard watch me do it
not for sure
there's no way you're going to finish in
the next two seconds
rest in peace aiden and kill switches
money
reflexive oh my gosh the island looks so
different yeah i kind of decimated it
let's make things more interesting if
you end up finding that chest not only
will you win ten thousand dollars but
i'll give your date a thousand dollars
oh now she has to go out with you i have
to find this all right moving on nova if
you hit that target you win money and
the further back you stand the more
money you win wow you get three shots
let's see how much money you can make
attempt the ten thousand dollar shot oh
all right take your time let's see how
good you are
oh he shot
oh
you were about two foot over man i'm not
gonna lie to you
all right you have two more shots you
completely butchered the first one so i
could like shoot it from over here maybe
a little bit more higher
oh
you're three quarters of a block away oh
my god wait you're going all the way
down for a thousand
okay ready wait oh i just want to scare
you
oh
next bit mango dragon you both have
exactly 10 minutes to build a realistic
looking version of chandler and whoever
has the best build wins ten thousand
dollars what oh boy ten minutes starts
now make me look good
you have eight minutes left we got some
legs you have a space between your legs
we're gonna talk about that i need space
title so what is this i'm doing a pixlr
i can't jam this looks like carl when
i'm stressed i confuse a lot of things
two one stop building this is the
chandler dragon built and this is the
chandler mango belt why does chandler
have a watermelon head what do you give
it out of ten four oh no on over to
dragon what does your gut say it's a
four they tied nolan your turn what do
you rate this one five out of ten what
do you rate stubby chandler it's not
chandler though so i gotta give this
a 3 out of 10.
dragon you just won
oh my god mango i don't want to send you
away with nothing we'll send you a
thousand as well ggs
good job
for this next bit i got 10 grand with
your name on it and all you have to do
to earn it is be one of the hardest
bosses in ginseng impact the sponsor of
this video oh that sounds easy enough go
come on get in here carl we got a lot of
damage to dude i'm coming in tension
impact is an open world action rpg game
available on pc android ios playstation
4 and playstation 5. and right now is
the perfect time to play ginger impact
because they're celebrating their one
year anniversary with two brand new
islands wait it's already been a year
how's the battle going it's going pretty
good right now
oh and on top of that there are big
events going on like a one one-year
anniversary online concert that's open
to everyone that sounds fun and genjin
has teamed up with horizon zero dong to
bring deloitte into the game wait that's
so cool so if you're interested in
starting kitchen impact use the link
description to get on pc mobile or
playstation now all right jimmy we're
done yay
perfect then after the video i'll give
you this ten thousand dollars let's go
back to giveaway money there are 100
random chandlers on this island and only
one of them is a real chandler hello you
must kill 10 chandlers and if one of
them is a real chandler i will give you
5 000 in cash good luck i don't know if
he's hiding or not am i looking at you
right now technically yeah
oh
one hit down
oh two swings down oh no
look i'll give you a hint i'm on the
island oh my god you're so helpful thank
you
wait are you seeing if chandler picks up
the sword that's so smart he might have
just cracked the code
chandler no trust your gut just go
slaughter some chandlers
oh my god whoa three swings i'm getting
nervous be very careful tune believe in
yourself two swings oh no
no only get away from me what oh maybe
he's up here
oh
you're taking too long you have 10
seconds oh no five guys oh my god three
two
no
well the real chandler please walk up
the tune i'm right here behind you oh
wait were you there the whole time what
the whole time here's a sword oh okay
see that innocent little child right
there if you can kill him before he
completes his parkour course i'll give
you five thousand dollars go oh dear god
get over here
oh oh oh carl's falling
oh
jimmy you nerd get back here
oh carl climb faster
pretty easy zooms would you like to do
double or nothing yeah sure then this
time carl has the diamond sword and has
to hunt you down good luck
yeah all right well now i gotta slow him
down
oh oh no and carl if you don't kill him
then you're garbage at minecraft
oh wait wait i didn't realize carl was
that close no
all right take your time take your time
let's go watch the piston
oh carl's on his tail
carl died i'm gonna cry
he did it oh my god you just went ten
thousand dollars what do you want to
tell the world subscribe to mr beast
this is ish you might remember him from
this video a year ago where he won two
thousand dollars and he asked for a
prius but obviously a prius cost more
than two grand so i told him no so he
then went out and did a hundred thousand
push-ups to be honest it was just to get
attention it worked you'll see an
obstacle course with rolling tires if
you can make it to the end of this
course without dying i will give you
your long-awaited prius how about it
not only is the prius on the line but so
is your pride were those hundred
thousand push-ups for nothing i really
hope not oh my gosh server speed the
tires no don't server don't this is
tough oh there's a tire coming at you
it's a big boy
oh watch out watch out oh no oh no oh
god oh oh wait
yes
ish just won a pre-ish yeah
this just shows you can be bothersome
and receive anything you want in life
word on the street is our boy reflexive
is very close to finding the money he's
actually on trajectory to hit it if he
continues strip mining let's see if we
can convince him to try something
different reflexive how you doing buddy
it's getting a little stressful i'm
gonna be honest i hate to break the news
to you but you're not even close you
have like five minutes left there's no
need for you to keep digging straight in
this direction i'm gonna stick to this
path dude that is so dumb trust me i'm
gonna keep going dude you're just gonna
keep mining in a straight line he's
probably never gonna find this thing you
sure you wanna go this way which way do
i wanna go i'm confused
oh my goodness wait a second hold up
hold up
congratulations you're ten thousand
dollars richer let's go you won ten
grand your day one one grand is it too
late for you to make it to your date it
is way too late yes if you're that girl
and you're watching this give him a
second chance subscribe goodbye